[Applause]
whatta ya say carving is weigh in on
kiss boots and that's a huge advantage
of floating off a is gonna score got six
already and now he'll be his Conference
Player goes against conference play
little pump right there back bumper on
the fly gets it to drop here at patient
nearby Colver trusting your players core
crews in for the first time both will
working on kiss Burt he'll watch it free
[Applause]
he comes up shot clock at nine outside
Novell glances at the clock 2010
audacity gets into fog will take a
two-point lead at halftime and this
would Texas Tech switching OT hace is on
Norville he falls down and that opens it
up inside eyes open put the ball was
down on the floor and Hannah's pregnant
Texas with the two he's got five off the
bench
[Applause]
shot clock at 10 outside Moretti Frank
don't want to file one of the big guys
going to the basket for an answer
Angemon yes / with a buoy rebound or
Bella balancing down
two-point game boom pop that suit of
arms picked up at cooking pizza that's
it there's a new member of the final
four club
[Applause]
Texas the red leaders at Texas Tech for
the first time in program history